president Trump heads to Argentina today
to meet with world leaders after as
stinging setback over the killing of
Washington Post contributor Jamal
khashoggi a large majority of the Senate
is pushing back against the president's
defense of Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman accused of ordering the
murder
the republican-led Senate vote Senate
voted 63 to 37 yesterday to end the US
military support for the saudi-led war
in Yemen even the president's closest
allies Senator Lindsey Graham voted in
favor
I changed my mind because I'm pissed the
way the administration's handled the
Saudi Arabia ven is just not acceptable
the briefing today did not help me at
all better understand the role of MBS
played in the killing of mr. ekeus OG
Lindsey Graham speaking there with his
gut
major Garrett is at the g20 meeting in
Buenos Aires with the challenges the
president faces there and at home major
good morning good morning as you
mentioned John that Senate resolution
seeks to cut off US military aid for
Saudi Arabia's long-running war with UT
rebels in Yemen it's essentially a proxy
war with its regional rival Iran now
yesterday the White House threatened to
veto any kind of congressional action of
this kind and that Senate vote clearly a
setback for the administration came
after a closed-door Senate briefing led
by Secretary of State Mike Pompeo and
the defense secretary James Madison
after that briefing mattis sidestepped
questions about Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman roll in cash oh geez death
telling reporters quote we have no
smoking gun he meaning the crown prince
was involved noticeably absent at that
briefing CIA director Gina Haspel whose
agency has overseen the u.s. side of the
khashoggi investigation past polls
absence prompted senators like Graham to
brand this briefing inadequate and
grandmas threatened to withhold of
support from any future legislation
including that which could keep the
government open and funded early next
month meanwhile Saudi Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman arrived here in
Argentina yesterday for the g20
President Trump has said he would meet
with him but there is currently nothing
on the schedule what is on the schedule
a high-stakes dinner here Saturday night
between President
and Chinese President Gigi p.m. in signs
both nations could be hurtling toward a
full-blown trade war earlier this week
the president's top economic advisors
criticized China for ignoring
long-standing US trade complaints and
yesterday both countries threatened to
impose yet another round of tariffs on
one another one other possible
development here the president is
scheduled to meet with Russian President
Vladimir Putin but Russian aggression
against Ukraine this past weekend Nora
could scuttle those talks there's gonna
be a lot of news coming out of that
summit there this weekend major Garrett
in Argentina thank you so much